on this episode I'm gonna talk about
humor billion-dollar ideas a tough patch
and I take the ALS challenge what's up
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 9 of the ask gary vee
show fun fact about the number 9 the
number 9 is jon halls number the pot
smoking wild kicker of the late 90s
early 2000 New York Jets Kyle asks
what's an area of life that you haven't
given your fullest efforts
great question you know and I probably
was willing to answer it because of how
good I feel about this question there
were two places 36 months ago that I was
struggling and one was kind of the
nonprofit NGO I was giving my dollars
but I wasn't giving my time now a very
proud member of the board of pencils of
promise and I've gotten more involved my
time which is the real asset and I feel
like I'm checking that box of giving
back outside of my own and family and
things of that nature and so I feel good
about that and the other one is my
health so I would say health was the
clear answer only 35 days ago I guess
now maybe a little bit more Gary time
you know between kids and the businesses
and now working out and like you know
AJ's been pushing me this you know he's
gotten into golf a little bit like oh
you know I'm I don't feel like I've been
able to figure out or crack or hack Gary
time right
I guess the Jets do that but then that's
really September to December I get that
Sunday 4 5 7 8 9 hours depending if it's
a homer road game I think January
through September finding something
that's just for me that I really enjoy
is something I should probably figure
out but the truth is that doesn't feel
right to me right now as the kids are 2
& 5 I want to kind of allocate to that
the health
I'm just prioritizing other stuff
hopeful
next two or three years Gary time shy
asks how does humor play a role in
business shy this is a really great
question and you've been known to ask me
great questions oh you thought I forgot
about we work I actually think it plays
a role but I would say it plays a role
in the way that it plays a role in all
of life humor happens to be one of the
most attractive personality traits I
mean look at the tragic events of this
week of Robin Williams the enormous
emotion an outcry and sadness and
feelings that have come from the
American public shows you like how much
a comedian can get very deeply ingrained
in the world and he was one of those
greats to you know I honestly use humor
I mean a lot of you watch my keynotes I
like the fancy and think that a lot of
my keynotes take on a stand-up comedy
routine I find myself having the ability
to drive difficult HR conversations and
selling things through to clients or to
the general public by leveraging humor I
think humor is an enormous ly attractive
trait that is a very important part of
business but no more important than the
other things that are people are very
attracted to and others which is caring
an empathy self-awareness gratitude
kindness beauty you know it's just
another core tenant that if you've got
it use it Mike asks is jab jab jab right
hook coming out in audiobook form Mike
I've been dodging this question on
Twitter for months so congratulations
for penetrating episode 9 the answer is
I was supposed to do it in like December
of last year January I kind of lagged
you know the two full days in in the
kind of booth were just became
unpractical because vaynermedia is
exploding and so alright I've been
watching this guy I've been watching you
a time yeah this time this time I've got
your number
uh-huh we got them this time guys we got
them so uh so where was like don't add
any of this
where was I recording booth no problem
yeah it was a practical baler
vaynermedia's exploding with characters
and uh and so I I just haven't gotten to
it and the truth is were thinking about
having somebody else read it it's just
kind of one of these things that are
dragging now and is lending itself to me
not doing it which I know is now gonna
get a ton of booze in the comment
section and I apologize Jason asks
what's the hardest thing you've had to
deal with in the past five years and how
did you get through it
Jason that is an intense question
actually you know what before I answer
that question I did a little something
fun for the audience and something
powerful I'd like to thank my little
contribution to the cause earlier this
morning
let's take a look and you garyvee tell
me if you want to accept my challenge
hashtag askgaryvee hey Jerry B and I'm
taking the ice bucket challenge
bring it me I know you love them
I challenge you
fëanor nation to step up so that was
interesting this morning Nate has never
been happier let's make sure we edit in
at Nate's handle in there so he gets a
little love I love when we give the
Vayner peeps some love now to a little
bit more of a somber serious question
Jason over the last five years the
hardest thing that I've had to deal with
you know hands down it has to be the
fact of siphoning off of Wine Library TV
daily grape that were teen of six years
and really leaving the day-in day-out
operations of the family business that
is the most emotional business you know
working with my dad kind of this
transition of being day in and day out
with my dad to being day in and day with
my brother enormous emotion comes with
that yeah I probably never even realized
that that would ever happen it was a
very big brain twist for me that I would
be transitioning out of the family
business into another chapter in my life
and I struggled with that quite a bit a
lot of heavy emotion the the
relationships and people at Wine Library
my dad and I dynamics just all these
very interesting things there was also
happening right when Misha was born it
was an interesting time in my life I was
it was growing up and and transitioning
and changing I I dealt with it with what
I deal with everything and really
probably the cornerstone of my happiness
I dealt with it by over communicating
the the level of communication I had
with the people involved was very high
and and allowed for it to happen and so
that's what I did
Damien asks when you have a billion
dollar potential business plan without
the financial resources in the inventory
where do you start with funding Damien
you know this is one of those questions
that I like picking for the show because
I'm always scared to be too rude to the
audience you guys are smiling
okay now I'm freaked out that eight
times doing stuff just you oh you guys
are worried about how much I'm about to
thrash Damien got it
Damien the the answer to that question
is very simple like we are in a bubble
of financing right now there are people
that would finance this venture
just an idea it's happened people come
in with a deck they have nothing people
give them money for a piece of the
business and they go and do it that's
your only option I mean there's nothing
else practical I mean you know anytime
somebody sets up a question of the
amount of time do many people have
emailed me with the title about to help
you buy the New York Jets or Gary open
this email and you will buy the New York
Jets or I'm gonna help you buy the New
York Jets and the next line is hey Gary
the fan of your work I have a billion
dollar idea
ideas are everybody's got an idea
speaking of ideas all sorts of ideas I
mean I I have unlimited ideas you know
if you if you have the idea that's nice
if you don't have the dollars and if you
don't have the inventory well you might
find to have nothing and so the only way
you do something about that is go and
get dollars from somebody to I assume
get the inventory and I don't understand
what the inventory is in this exact
question
but the reason I'm answering this
question is the entire vaynernation to
to understand that practicality matters
right passion which I'm loaded with is
great right ideas transcend the word
world
great agreed but in execution in
practicality is when these things become
true that's what matters
that's what the people we all look up to
have done they've taken from here and
they've made it happen and so that is
massively important and that is
something I push all of you to start
spending some more time on question of
the day for episode 9 who who in your
family inspires you the most
turn them up give them some love it's a
good thing to do you keep asking
questions and I'll keep answering them
on this episode I'm gonna chase that
employee that's [ __ ] with me
outtake secretly I think the reason I'm
even doing this show is cuz I realize
I'm in the midst of this health
transformation and I'm kind of excited
to watch me transform into the
Incredible Hulk or the course of the
next couple of years yeah subscribe